bien alors jean paul au boulot vous êtes
ici pour le film de richard berry qui
s'appelle moi césar 10 ans et demi un
maître 39 où vous avez retrouvé
on y revient toujours le petit jules
sitruk le petit garçon de monsieur
batignole le film qui vous a valu un
oscar à hollywood
monsieur rouve monsieur rouge voilà
alors c'est deuxième film de richard
berry c'est l'histoire de césar donc dix
ans et demi à m 39 5 kilos en trop le
petit doigt me des prothèses
oui c'était même dur je croyais tout
mais ça ils avaient 10 irritations et
tous un enfer apparaît soudain voilà le
petit les fous amoureux de sarah qui
joué par joséphine berry la fille de
richard berry a et non par les jeane
manson cette fois dû mais avec jessica
ford
voilà faisons l'amour avant le mondial
je n'ai plus d'un c'est quand il serait
bienvenu sur ces pannes ou le chant des
noms faisant la moue avant de nous dire
adieu à huy
c'est qu'on est là
bien oui ninon 2 il ne chante bien ouais
le beau gosse leveaux voit qu'elle est
une pierre et jean romans un moment où
cet homme est un génie et lison robben
mais alors donc ce petit ce petit césar
d'emploi amoureux de sarah il n'a aucune
chance passe à son meilleur ami m'a
beaucoup y actes et voilà ça c'est son
rival qu'un métis blond comme ça
magnifique et cet univers de césar et
des cris c'est toute l'idée du film à
hauteur des yeux d'un enfant voilà ce
qui fait que évidemment ça donne une
impression qu'on n'a pas connue depuis
très longtemps
qu'est ce qu'on ne voit on te voilà
voilà
vrai que tu vois les coûts ne vois la
magnifique